these are scientists in particular being
a theoretical physicist we are what I
like to call hopeless optimist now what
do I mean by this well when we look at
the world obviously there are many many
conditions of humanity that cause us to
despair hunger poverty war bigotry and
so it would be easy to lose hope if you
just look at these parts and of human
behavior on the other hand if you're a
theoretical physicist you're doing
something that you were likely if if
you're doing it it's at its most
fundamental level you're doing something
that most likely in your lifetime you
will never see a single fruit coming
from it and so you're creating ideas and
what I like to call the storehouse of
human knowledge in order for these ideas
to become a value however it will take
time it's a little bit like putting a
note in a bottle and simply casting the
bottle into the sea with the hope that
someone will find this note and it will
be of value to them that's what doing
theoretical physics is like on one hand
so I understand that that's the life
I've chosen for myself it's a life where
we get to think about the universe and
it's a life where at the end of the day
it's a it's a personal engagement with
the universe at a profound level on the
other hand it's not something that that
I think of as separating me from the
rest of humanity because in fact the
whole point of the exercise is to do
something valuable for Humanity there is
a wonderful saying by Horace ma man who
said and you should be ashamed to die
before you have won some great victory
for humankind and that's what's being a
physicist a theoretical physicists like
you're trying to make that that
wonderful victory for humankind and so
it's a profoundly connecting sense of
what it is that we do
so when I look at the world and as you
brought up the American Idol I
understand that for most people these
are things that are important to them
personally that bring great value to
their existence on the other hand for
someone like me for example I've never
actually seen American Idol I know it
exists because I hear about it all the
time but I don't for me personally I
don't see a point so doing theoretical
physics is to me profoundly a human
activity because it's an expression of
optimism in our species and that's why I
say we are hopeless